First, let's describe the function, as the problem asked.
We have a function: "printmultiplicationtable"
that takes in one number that we called "n".
If you looked at the output in the example,
you'll notice that the first operand goes from 1 to "n".
Let's write the "while" loop that does that.
Here, we called the first operand "i".
Now let's think about the second operand.
For every value of the first operand, it goes from 1 to "n".
Let's write a second "while" loop
inside this "while" loop to do just that.
We called our second operand "j".
Everything in the body of this "while" loop
is indented twice over from the beginning:
once for the function definition, and another time for the "while" loop.
Everything in the inner "while" loop is indented 3 times:
once for the function definition,
once for the first "while" loop,
and a third time for this inner "while" loop.
The last thing that remains is printing the output.
This may look right, but we have to remember
that we can't add a number and a string.
If you looked at the hint below the question, you know that
the "str" function will turn any integer into a string.
>From there, we can add the 2 strings.
[Yay! Nested Loops!]